قيس سعيد الرئيس التونسي ينوي اعاده
العلاقات مع النظام السوري المنقطعه منذ
عام 2012 عده كتل برلمانيه تونسيه ادى
ايدت عوده العلاقات على امل ان يتعاون
نظام الاسد مع تحقيقات تجريها المحاكم
التونسيه في ملف تسفير تونسيين الى بؤر
التوتر في سوريا للقتال في صفوف تنظيم
داعش علي العريض رئيس الوزراء التونسيه
الاسبق التابع لحركه النهضه الاخوانيه كان
قد تم تحويله الى القضاء في ذات الملف
الرئيس التونسي قال ان مساله النظام في
سوريا تهم السوريين وحدهم وان تونس تتعامل
مع الدوله السوريه مؤكدا انه ليس هناك ما
يبرر ان يكون هنالك سفير لتونس في سوريا
وسفير لدمشق في تونس
ليس هناك ما يبرر ان لا يكون هناك سفير
لتونس في دمشق في الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه
وسفير للجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه في تونس
مساله
النظام في سوريا مساله تهم السوريين وحدهم
نحن نتعامل مع الدوله السوريه اما
اختيارات الشعب السوري فهي اختياراته ولا
دخل لنا فيها اطلاقا